[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
voit là les amis je suis en loge
quelques minutes devant spectacle aux
ménuires du rire organisé par florent
peyre yann arthus qu'elle a les a mis là
je vais monter sur scène j'ai les
copains voilà je vais monter sur scène
donc je vais vous demander de quitter la
loge allez on y va rohmer ou mais allez
salut salut et vous
allez artus oui
comment mentir au peuple
s'est pas
jetée tranquillement mon argent s'est
passé pas de même bizarre là y'a d'la
way d'ailleurs
tu meures monde aux essais mais sakho
base de
données as-tu ferme en plus
tu en as
you go bleu
mai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non s'ils perdurent jamais y arriver non
mais j'ai faire face ils ont garé il
faut il dit pose ta capuche taka positif
et a pu s'y pose ta capuche t'as qu'à
poser ta capuche ouais c'est pas fou
aurait peut-être fera de moi
ok maintenant qui va
voilà c'est pas mal aussi
dommage en petite vidéo et je réagis
voici la musique la plus relaxante du
monde selon la science ah ouais donc la
musique apparemment l2 dans la jeu peu
détendu là
cette musique est un fond sonore dans
cette vidéo elle est capable de détendre
n'importe qui en quelques minutes peu
pour le don de soi juste total donc des
doigts favorite des fois que kaka de
répit au possible il m'a répondu ah ils
m'ont remis l'un est parfois tard garde
à vous je président du là